from the president and the Secretary
General to the troll a platform
welcoming you to Norway this is a
central part of Norway and it
illustrates the energy partnership and
security partnership between Norway and
Europe in these very demanding times
during this year we've had intense
cooperation and contact between the
European commission and Norway this is
the first visit by a commission
president since 2011 to Norway and we
appreciate to see her here
Norway has been able to increase gas
supplies to Europe during this year and
it's our ambition to be able to hold
that high level for the next four to
five years so we are between 30 and 40
percent of Europe's deliveries this
platform in itself provides 10 percent
of Europe's gas consumption just to
highlight the dimensions
this is also of course about security
and I would salute the commission
presidents for having so strongly
contributed to European unity in face of
the Russian attack war on Ukraine and
the Secretary General also for keeping
NATO allies so solely solely together
and one Norwegian contribution to this
Unity for democracy and freedom is that
we maintain our level as a secure energy
provider
and let me also add that this energy
effort is also about speeding up the
energy transition
so we have been working very closely
with the commission to venture into
offshore wind hydrogen the new energy
sources and in a few years from this
platform you may be observing offshore
windmills producing renewable energy for
our economy and for the European economy
I would also like to highlight that the
German Chancellor and I took an
initiative
to ask NATO to be coordinating
uh security
initiatives for our energy installations
Norway has about 90 offshore
installations
8 000 kilometers of Pipelines
and it is a very good sign that NATO can
take a responsibility in coordinating
our efforts to secure that security with
industry and with governments so both of
you close friends you are heartily
welcome to troll this is a part of
Norway
Madam president
thank you very much
um Jonas thank you very much for the
invitation it's the very first time in
my life that I am on the gas rig so it's
amazing it's really exciting and indeed
Norway has been a incredibly precious
partner and friend to the European Union
mainly in the last 12 months while we
saw this atrocious war that Russia
Unleashed against Ukraine
Putin tried to Blackmail the European
Union by cutting us off a Russian gas
supply 80 percent an equivalent of 100
billion cubic meter of cubic meter of
gas that Putin has stopped going to the
European Union and in that time we
needed friends and like-minded partners
to step up and that's what Norway did
Norway increased its production and
helped us in a critical time it
increased the production from 78 billion
cubic meter to 90 billion cubic meter
and this really helped us through the
winter we're grateful for that and we
are very happy to hear that in the years
to come we will maintain this high level
of support but of course our friendship
and partnership is much much broader
than only natural gas indeed we are
working on a green Alliance the green
Alliance that's basically the Champions
League we the European Union have only
one Greener line so far with Japan and
now Norway will be the first country in
Europe to have a green alliance with the
European Union
we're working on decarbonization we're
working indeed on hydrogen green
hydrogen we're interested in carbon
capture and storage of course here in
Norway you are champions what offshore
wind and wind onshore also is concerned
you have the wind and you have the
technology so everything is open to
create the screen Alliance I'm very much
looking forward to do that my third
point is on security indeed
the last month taught us how important
it is to protect our critical
infrastructure and here Jens I'm very
grateful that together with NATO the
European Union created a task force we
had the very first meeting of this task
force to for the protection of the
critical infrastructure yesterday
what is the principle
um the European Union and NATO both have
a very clear view on the threat theater
and an assessment on the situation but
we come from different angles and
therefore if we join forces we have a
broader View and of course we are also
able to find more solutions to protect
our critical infrastructure so in some
it's great to be here among friends and
thank you for the excellent cooperation
yes it's over to you thank you
first of all uh CEO on this Opera it's a
great pleasure to be at this platform
again and I'm glad to be here together
with the Prime Minister unosco and to
graduate president USA from The Lion
these structures are really impressive
and we all know that they helped to heat
homes and power industry across Europe
so therefore gas installations like the
troll platform is vital for our
economies for our Industries but also
therefore for our security because we
have seen
um
uh how President Putin has tried to use
energy as a weapon throughout the war
against Ukraine and Norwich has helped
to
respond to that and ensure that the
President Putin failed in this attempt
to use energy as a weapon
um
since these structures are so vital
they're also vulnerable and the NATO has
addressed the security of offshore
installations of undersea infrastructure
for many years but now we have stepped
up not least because of the initiative
taken by prime minister starter and Sean
sir Schultz some months ago to give NATO
a more a stronger role in the efforts of
making sure that his vital
infrastructure is a safe and secure so I
thank you for the initiative this has
really led to some concrete action
within the alliance
then we also stepped our cooperation
with the European Union and as president
uh USAF online just mentioned NATO and
the European Union has established or we
have established a Joint Task Force they
met for the first time yesterday and we
are now stepping up the concrete
cooperation with the European Union to
complement and to work closer together
to ensure critical industry
infrastructure and offshore offshore
installations like these this platform
uh NATO has also increased its presence
with more military capabilities in the
North Sea in the in the Baltic Sea and
also elsewhere and as we speak there is
a Norwegian Coast Guard over there there
is an original helicopter in the air and
uh and uh and uh and this uh there is a
German ship back uh behind and you just
saw a maritime Patrol aircraft and this
is part of NATO's standing Maritime
group with ships and and planes from
many different NATO Nations
demonstrating how NATO allies stand
together in uh in protecting these vital
infrastructure so in a more dangerous
World in a more unpredictable world it's
even more important that we stand
together and ensure these kinds of
extremely important infrastructure for
our economies for our daily life and
also for our security so thank you so
much again honors
yeah let me move yeah okay
thank you very much uh Madam president
uh Secretary General and prime minister
thank you very much for visiting the
troll a platform it's your pleasure for
us to to welcome you you're here
um and this really underlines the
importance of the energy cooperation
between Norway and also EU and Europe
uh the troll field that we are today I
guess the Prime Minister said can
produce 10 of Europe's consumption uh
every day and we plan to produce gas
from this installation Beyond 2050. but
as the Prime Minister said in addition
to securing a gas to Europe this area
will possibly also produce electrons
from offshore wind and just a few
kilometers from here next year we will
start storing CO2 that we will actually
pick up from ships in Europe and bring
uh to uh close to the troll field and
then Pump It Down safely in the ground
so this area will be an important area
you know in the cooperation between
Europe and Norway also for many many
decades equinor we are dedicated to a
balanced energy transition and we will
continue developing the energy Norway
and Europe will need for decades so
thank you again for it's a really a
pleasure to having all of you here with
us here today thank you
um
healthy and receive threat specifically
typically from Russia to this critical
infrastructure and then second of all
how much more important has this become
a special to the Riverview now that most
European Union member states are
off-russian gas and turning more towards
uh Gasper Norway
first of all this infrastructure is
extremely important it's vital but that
makes it also vulnerable not at least
because of the share size we speak about
thousands of kilometers of pipelines SO
gas and oil but also
other kinds of internet cable power
cables so in totality this is an
enormous amount of infrastructure
meaning that of course you cannot
protect every meter of this
infrastructure at every time but what we
do is that we have stepped off what we
do when it comes to exchanging
intelligence information more closely
monitoring the infrastructure then we
have increased our presence with more
military capabilities and then the plan
is also now to exercise more to be able
to react fast if something happens
one thing which is illustrated by the
task force we have established on the on
the on the enhanced uh vigilance NATO
allies are now showing when it comes to
protecting critical undersea
infrastructure is that we work more
closely with the private sector
companies like Equinox and Ecuador and
uh and the CEO actually went they
already came to the NATO headquarters
briefed the North Atlantic Council
because we know that the private
companies that have key capabilities
which are essential for the protection
of this uh infrastructure when it comes
to Ports of European Union
yes thank you indeed um
critical infrastructures of critical
importance to all of us and we have
decided to start together with the EO
NATO join task force to protect the
critical infrastructure to look at our
vulnerabilities
um for example at vulnerabilities in the
energy sector or the transport sector
but also digital and space is important
it is first of all about having a mutual
awareness about what the threats are a
common analysis about the strength and
the weaknesses and then to develop
together a different solution for better
protection
and as I said as we have different
angles at which we look with which we
look at the different theaters joining
forces of course widens our
possibilities to protect our critical
infrastructure and this infrastructure
here speaking of Norway and the
importance for the European Union it is
of high importance so we have seen how
critical and crucial it was for the
European Union to make it through the
winter that Norway stepped up its
production and this was of course
through this infrastructure that is in
place so we were in a clear crisis and
we were able to react rapidly and
actively to this crisis thanks to this
critical infrastructure
my question is regarding the prices of
gas and oil especially gas which has led
to a lot of discomfort around Europe
what do you see Norway's role in
lowering these prices keeping them
acceptably low have you had any talks
prime minister about this question so
first of all why have the prices
skyrocketed this was not a normal Market
anymore this was a manipulated market
and lots of speculation in because when
the prices last summer exploded this was
because President Putin took of 100
billion cubic meters of gas off the
global market and of course this
tightened enormously the market this was
a strategic decision of President Putin
and this was not a normal Market
reaction the moment we acted in unity
the European Union with friends and
allies to diversify away from Russia to
compensate prices went down this is
point number one so Point number two we
are just tabling as European union and
electricity Market form and we have
created a joint energy platform
to make it possible for our suppliers to
have the aggregated demand of the
European Union for example for Norway to
join this platform as a supplier and the
aim is not only to have the spot Market
but to look at long-term contracts that
are beneficial for both sides and with
that we have the consumer at the core of
our action and this is what brings us
together
yeah let me say that Norway is served by
stable prices we don't set prices for
gas and these volatile high prices is
not in Norway's interest
directly for Norway because gas prices
Drive electricity prices which are very
high for Norwegian consumers and that's
a burden on them and on industry
secondly it's not good for our partners
in Europe they are our allies and our
trading partners so one contribution has
been to increase our export has
contributed to Bringing prices down and
I I take note of the fact that the
company is operating on the Shelf are in
close contact with the European Partners
on more long-term agreements following
very closely what happens on the
purchasing side and we've had
politically contact on this also between
the commission and the god Norwegian
government to see what we can do to
contribute to more stability prices have
come down but as the president said it
is basically because there is now more
energy coming in and that's what we have
to see through that we now can also push
in more renewable energy to help
stabilize the markets